my name is andristavnitzer i used to run
the largest port in ukraine however my
business is
idle for the last
40 days or so there are no ships coming
into ukraine for 40-ish days
most of the ships that were they're
locked in ukraine are now ghost ships
roughly half a billion people around the
world depend or rely on our grain not on
the grain but also by products like
sunflower oil and rapeseed oil and soy
if we do not open the ports we do not
unlock those millions of tons of grains
that are in the country a huge food
crisis could be triggered by this
especially in african countries
our farmers are brave enough to to do
seeding
uh
in the time of bombing so basically when
the truck when the famous ukrainian
tractors are not busy with the
hunting russian tanks
they are doing seeding campaign right
now actually i like those names
currently we are running uh
three
humanitarian centers
we are now also working towards
mres meals ready to eat
because it's becoming an issue uh you
know their logistical logistical chains
are being cut off i just talked to
friends of mine who were
under a blocked
they were in a blocked house
for two weeks
they couldn't get out because they were
surrounded by russians they ran out of
food completely and
these are these are my friends i know
them very well they've been eating
dog food you know the drug dried dog
food because there was no more food to
eat
[Music]
one of the options would be that
ukrainian
ukrainian grain is exported with convoys
of military vessels from international
international community in with the
convoy of
nato or
turkish military vessels
[Music]
europe has paid 35 billion
billion euros for gas
in the 40 days and you know how much
weapons they give us
slightly more than a billion
so i mean what are we talking about this
europe is is co-sponsoring this bloody
massacre in chromatorsh in bucha etc and
we only get 1 billion in weapons